[Musique]
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet portant séparation des Églises et
de l'État la République
assure la liberté de conscience et
garantie le libre exercice des cultes
qui l'Église ne peut se passer de
subside de l'État c'est que l'Église est
déjà morte à eux
toutes les opinions pourront s'exprimer
des ennemis de la République aurait beau
jeu dans cette partie voulez-vous
détruire le catholicisme dans ce pays
voulez-vous anéantir la religion
c'est la majeure veuillez faire silence
messieurs la France n'est pas
gismatique elle est révolutionnaire
nous ne faisons pas
une œuvre de brutalité nous faisons une
oeuvre de sincérité
[Musique]
de la liberté faut d'abord savoir
respecter la liberté d'autrui
au lieu de désarmer l'église lui donner
des armes voyez-vous
ça serait une opinion j'ai le droit de
l'exposer respecter le déroulement de la
série que vous ne déclarez c'est la
guerre que vous nous apportez
ça suffit une confiscation n'est pas une
solution équitable quel est le but que
vous vous
proposez un jour annoncelle des étoiles
mais nous vibres penseurs venez ne
séparation que
nous vous
[Musique]
bien cela ça n'est pas la conception
de la libre pensée du moins telle que je
l'interprète
[Musique]
la République peut-elle accepter le port
ustensile de signes religieux
qui doit financer les édifices du culte
l'Europe doit-elle revendiquer ses
origines chrétiennes
la France doit-elle entretenir une
relation privilégiée avec le Vatican
[Musique]
autant de polémiques autant de sujets
brûlants
en 1905 déjà les élus de la nation se
posaient les mêmes questions
à l'Assemblée nationale de gros volumes
reliés renferme l'histoire de la laïcité
à la française
[Musique]
une histoire ancienne mouvementée
violente même
la Révolution française a rompu l'unité
de l'État et de la religion le roi n'est
plus le représentant de Dieu sur terre
les biens du clergé sont confisqués de
nombreux prêts de sont exécutés
[Musique]
la France est ravagée par la guerre
civile
c'est pour ramener la paix religieuse
que Napoléon Bonaparte négocie avec le
Pape Pie 7 en 1801 il signe le Concordat
la religion catholique est
officiellement reconnue comme celle de
la majorité des Français les prêtres
deviennent des fonctionnaires de l'État
chargés d'assurer le service public des
cultes et perçoivent un traitement mais
doivent jurer fidélité au régime les
pasteurs protestants les rabbins seront
logés à la même enseigne mais Napoléon
ajoute d'autorité une série d'articles
organiques qui réglementent jusqu'à la
vie des prêtres et leur interdit toute
initiative sans la permission du
gouvernement
première cause de conflit ces articles
organiques ne seront jamais reconnus par
l'Église
seconde cause de conflits cette église
fonctionnarisée va soutenir tous les
régimes autoritaires et monarchiques qui
se succèdent au 19e siècle
alors l'opposition républicaine devient
farouchement anticléricale des 1869
Gambetta réclame la séparation des
Églises et de l'État c'est à dire
l'abolition du Concordat
Leclerc hécanisme voilà l'ennemi
quand ils arrivent au pouvoir les
républicains laïcissent le pays de
France s'oppose celle du curé et celle
de l'instituteur celle du croyant et
celle du libre penseur
[Musique]
à partir de 1902 on assiste à de vrais
batailles rangées que suscite la
politique anti-cléricale menée par le
gouvernement des millecondes expulsion
des congrégations religieuses rupture
des relations diplomatiques avec le
Vatican le Concordat devient
inapplicable
éclate enfin l'affaire des fiches on
découvre que le général André ministre
de la guerre fait fichier les officiers
qui vont à la messe le scandale est-elle
que le gouvernement compte finit par
être renversé
c'est alors que s'engage la grande
bataille parlementaire de 1905
[Musique]
le nouveau président du Conseil Rouvier
voudrait éviter la guerre religieuse
mais le 10 février contre son souhait
les députés votent la tenue d'un débat
sur la séparation
le ministre des Cultes Jean-Baptiste
bienvenue Martin dépose un projet de loi
sous la présidence de Ferdinand Buisson
une commission spéciale prépare le débat
[Musique]
21 mars 1905 s'ouvre la première séance
de la discussion parlementaire qui va
durer toute l'année
[Musique]
un débat fleuves 48 séances de combat
passionnés dans l'hémicycle 1500 pages
de compte rendu au Journal officiel
[Musique]
député du Finistère la bégayero au nom
de l'église va défendre une motion
visant à journée le débat
[Musique]
la séance est ouverte
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet et de plusieurs propositions de
loi
portant séparation des Églises et de
l'État
la parole est à Monsieur la bégayraud
[Musique]
messieurs
je ne crois pas que depuis 1789 un débat
plus important que celui qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui est eu lieu dans une chambre
française
vous savez que je ne recule pas devant
l'expression de mes pensées ni devant
l'affirmation nette et précise de la
doctrine catholique je vais donc si vous
le permettez vous dire ici très
franchement ce que l'Église catholique
enseigne est-ce que tous les fidèles
enfants de cette église croix
relativement à la séparation de l'Église
et de l'État pour nous messieurs
l'idéal des rapports entre l'Église et
l'État ne sauraient être la séparation
pour nous l'idéal c'est l'union de la
société civile et de la société
religieuse la domination du pape
[Applaudissements]
pour la paix des consciences pour la
tranquillité publique
et ne croyez pas que le Concordat
napoléonien réalise cette idéal non non
ne croyez pas que nous considérions le
Concordat comme l'expression fidèle de
la doctrine catholique parce qu'il fait
nos prêtres des fonctionnaires de l'État
l'église n'est pas reconnue comme la
vraie religion non
ce qu'elle est à nos yeux mais comme la
religion du plus grand nombre des
Français ça ne vous suffit pas
en outre il y a les fameuses articles
organiques
ajoutez unilatéralement par Napoléon
pour contrôler l'église et que le Saint
Siège ne reconnaît pas enfin je ferai
remarquer que la manière dont se
concordat a été appliqué surtout dans
les derniers temps a fait de lui un
instrument d'oppression contre l'Église
et contre les consciences catholiques
c'est pas pour
[Applaudissements]
veiller me permettre de développer ma
pensée dans le calme j'ai besoin ici
croyez-le de toute ma tranquillité
d'esprit
chaque orateur il y a droit
[Applaudissements]
vous le voyez mes chiens je ne regarde
pas le Concordat comme l'idéal des
rapports entre l'Église et l'État
et cependant je n'hésite pas à déclarer
que je préfère encore ce régime
concordataire à la séparation que vous
nous apportez par la séparation en effet
l'église deviendra dans ce pays une
association semblable à toutes les
autres peut-être très bien
son caractère divin sera méconnu nié par
la loi et par le gouvernement
messieurs toutes les opinions pourront
s'exprimer ne perdez pas dès maintenant
vos forces en interruption avec la
séparation l'État lui-même perdra son
autorité sur le clergé
et compromettra gravement les avantages
que sa qualité de Première nation
catholique il faisait dans le monde
c'est vrai vous prétendez
accorder la liberté à l'église
évoluer le budget des cultes
je lis votre projet la République ne
reconnaît ne Solary ni ne subventionne
aucun culte mais quel est le but que
vous vous proposez
voulez-vous détruire le catholicisme
dans ce pays voulez-vous anéantir la
religion
vous les vous entraver la liberté des
consciences chrétiennes catholique
protestant israélite
nous avons des siècles pour prendre leur
revanche et l'histoire nous apprend
qu'elle vienne toujours
aussi je vous en conjure messieurs si
vous voulez faire oeuvre libérale
pacificatrice si vous voulez dans ce
pays profondément catholique malgré tout
vous le savez bien calmer les
appréhensions légitimes de nos
consciences vous devez vous devez non
pas à cause de notre foi non je
n'invoque pas cette raison qui se révèle
à vos yeux mais à cause du principe
fondamental de nos constitutions
politiques
qui est le respect de la liberté de
conscience prendre les mesures
naturellement indiquées pour donner à
nos consciences catholiques la
satisfaction qu'elles sont en droit de
réclame
n'oubliez pas qu'au dessus des lois que
vous pouvez faire il y a le droit de
Dieu et la liberté des consciences
catholiques ne l'oubliez pas
sur ce point nous ne transigions jamais
nous avons fait nos preuves depuis 2000
ans
lorsque sonne l'heure des persécutions
quelques violentes qu'elles soient nous
savons y mettre la tête
et lorsque nous y avons mis la tête
prenez-y garde
vous serez les vaincus messieurs
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fini je m'excuse d'avoir si
longtemps retenu votre attention
je suis venu à cette tribune
parler non pas tant en catholique et en
prêtre quand citoyen soucieux de la paix
sociale de son pays si vous ne voulez
pas accepter la motion que je propose je
suis persuadé que vous le regretterez un
jour je prévois de grands mots de grand
malheur pour l'Église et pour la France
c'est la guerre que vous nous déclarez
c'est la guerre que vous nous apportez
et nous la ferons
quoi qu'il en soit je tiens à l'affirmer
du haut de cette tribune c'est avec une
grande tristesse que je verrai le vote
de ce projet
qui c'est un gant jeté à la phase de
l'église et bien nous le relèverons et
nous verrons qui reculera
magnifique pour la France catholique
[Musique]
pour nous l'idéal c'est l'union de la
société civile et de la société
religieuse
vous allez ouvrir une période de trouble
en allumant dans ce pays une sorte de
guerre civile toujours
[Musique]
après le prêche enflammé du perquéo les
conversations vont bons trains dans les
couloirs du Palais Bourbon
[Musique]
le silence du gouvernement est très
commenté ni le président du conseil ni
le ministre des Cultes ne semble décider
à se mettre en avant dans un débat
qu'ils n'ont pas souhaité et qu'il
aurait été imposé par les députés
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion du
projet portant séparation des Églises et
de l'État
[Musique]
c'est donc Aristide Briand le rapporteur
de la commission qui va défendre la
séparation
Aristide Briand sera-t-il à la hauteur
lycéen il avait séduit Jules Verne par
sa forte personnalité le jeune brillant
héros du roman deux ans de vacances
c'est lui un adolescent français qui
triomphe de toutes les difficultés sur
l'île déserte en ira-t-il de même dans
l'hémicycle
[Musique]
avocat spécialisé dans les conflits du
travail Aristide Briand à la parole
facile mais il n'en a pas moins subi
trois échecs au législatives avant
d'entrer au Palais Bourbon
il n'est député que depuis trois ans et
certains de ses collègues s'étonnent
qu'un dossier d'une telle importance
était confié à un débutant
le rapporteur est aussi desservi par sa
réputation sulfureuse
élevée dans le café concert que tenait
ses parents parmi les buveurs et les
filles Aristide Briand et présenté par
ses adversaires comme un cynique et un
débauché
né à Nantes il a dû partir à
Saint-Étienne pour devenir député à
cause d'un scandale de mœurs jeune
militants socialiste on la trouvait un
jour en plein champ avec la femme d'un
important banquier de la région
longtemps proche de l'extrême gauche
influencé par l’anarko syndicalisme il
est connu comme un collectiviste
partisan de la grève générale
peu nombreux sont les députés qui
parient sur Aristide Briand
mais ses amis comptent sur son art
oratoire et sur son invité
[Applaudissements]
en assistant longuement auprès de vous
pour que vous repoussiez la motion de
Monsieur l'abeille
je craindrai de faire un jus à la
chambre car ce serait la supposée
capable de se déjger à un mois
d'intervalle
[Musique]
il y a un mois en effet vous avez
déclaré à une forte majorité que les
circonstances
ayant rendu inévitable la séparation des
Églises et de l'État la discussion et le
vote de la réforme s'imposait de toute
nécessité dans cette session même
c'était un engagement solennel pris en
pleine connaissance de cause et devant
le pays tout entier depuis la situation
s'est-elle modifiée mais non monsieur
non elle est restée
identiquement la même
des difficultés à apprendre ne se sont
pas à planis d'ailleurs Israël
parfaitement puériles d'espérer qu'elle
puisse être jamais aplanie car ils
tiennent à des causes profondes sur
lesquelles pas pu le Saint Siège que la
République ne peuvent transiger nous
nous trouvons devant une situation
inextricable toutes les causes de
conflits persistent
pour la République les principaux
avantages du Concordat je devrais dire
tout le Concorde sont dans les articles
organiques or ces articles Rome ne les a
jamais reconnus toujours à toutes les
époques elle a déclaré les tenir pour
nul et non avenir d'ailleurs la doctrine
fondamentale de l'église oppose
formellement
c'est la tare originale de cette
convention interlope née dans la
contrainte dans la rue
à la suite de violation successives et
pour ainsi dire systématique du concorva
les relations avec Rome ont dû être
rompu vous avez approuvé cette rupture
le mois dernier vous allez reconnu que
la situation à peine une solution rapide
et que la seule qui fut à la fois
acceptable et conforme à la dignité et
aux intérêts de la République étaient
là séparation des Églises et de l'État
[Musique]
avec toutes les fractions de la chambre
pour discuter non plus sur une misérable
question de procédure
mais sur le fond même de la réforme
c'est à l'heure où la chambre s'apprête
à entreprendre la tâche qu'elle s'est
assignée qu'on lui propose
la journée toute solution et bien dans
ce cas là que se passera-t-il messieurs
mais c'est très simple si vous aviez
l'imprudence
d'accorder c'est ta journée de Saint
Siège ne manquerait pas il aurait raison
d'interpréter votre vote
comme le signe d'une grande inquiétude
comme la démonstration de votre
impuissant comme la preuve éclatante
que vous redoutez de prendre les
responsabilités de leur ils croirait
simplement que vous êtes respectueux du
suffrage universel monsieur le comte de
Baudry Dasson je vous invite à faire
silence
le rapporteur seul à la parole de sa
siège
son attitude n'en serait pas améliorer
ni ses prétentions affaiblies mais ceci
n'est rien rien à côté de ce qui
pourrait se passer dans le pays
les ennemis de la République auraient
beau jeu dans cette partie là
le champ serait librement ouvert devant
eux à tous les mensonges
à toutes les calomnies contre ce régime
sur cette question de la séparation que
vous auriez posé mais sans la résoudre
de vous prêter des pires dessins
éloignez de vos intentions
vous les verriez parcourir les campagnes
annonçant la fermeture des églises
de montrer la vérité aux électeurs
veuillez faire silence messieurs si vous
ne pouvez pas entendre exprimer des
opinions qui ne sont pas les vôtres la
discussion ne peut pas continuer
les ennemis de la République
vous les verriez parcourir les campagnes
annonçant la fermeture des églises la
transcription des prêtres la persécution
des fidèles
et les atteintes les plus graves à la
liberté de conscience et alors vous
messieurs vous comment pourriez-vous
vous défendre contre ces attaques si
grossières tiens vraisemblable futel bah
vous ne pourriez pas
vous ne pourriez pas car quand on a
l'imprudence de s'exposer à être jugé
sur des intentions
on peut craindre toutes les erreurs
tout est injustices
alors monsieur je vous le demande quel
est le républicain qui consentirait de
gaieté de cœur à jeter la République
dans une aventure aussi folle faites un
référendum sur cette question vous
verrez le résultat vraiment messieurs il
est inadmissible que l'on ne puisse pas
continuer dans le calme et le silence
une discussion dans les termes ou
celle-ci est bonnet
tu nous apportions à l'étude et au vote
d'un projet de séparation la même
passion
et le même à tolérance que vous mettez
dans cette discussion nous vous ferions
bien mauvaise loi contre laquelle vous
auriez raison de protester mais je
n'insiste plus je m'excuse auprès de la
Chambre d'en avoir tandis pour démontrer
à quel point est inacceptable
cette motion d'ajournement
enfin cette discussion aura tout de même
malue à l'église un petit délai et je
crois que dans les circonstances
passantes nous sommes
et tout ce que nous pouvons faire pour
elle
bouée d'un talon d'orateur qui a étonné
la chambre Aristide Briand a défendu la
séparation sans même avoir eu besoin de
détailler le contenu du texte
bon tacticien le rapporteur a préféré
mettre les députés devant leur
responsabilités au moment où l'ouverture
du débat parlementaire créé dans le pays
une agitation qui ne peut durer
je mets au voile la motion de Monsieur
l'abbé Guero qui est pour
qui est contre
[Musique]
elle n'est pas adoptée
mais Aristide Briand n'est pas au bout
de ses peines après avoir rallié les
modérés au principe de la séparation il
lui reste à affronter l'extrême gauche
qui lui reproche la tiédeur de son texte
Maurice Allard député socialiste du Var
a déposé un contre-projet fils d'un
notaire touranjo Maurice allarne manque
jamais l'occasion de faire oublier ses
origines bourgeoises par des positions
doctrinales
ultra rouge
ancienne avocat devenu journaliste le
député de Draguignan est connu pour sa
facilité de parole et sa verve caustique
en matière religieuse Maurice Allard
passe pour un des anticléricaux les plus
enragés de la chambre dès 1903 il a
réclamé la fermeture de l'ambassade de
France auprès du Vatican
plusieurs fois il a demandé la
suppression des aumôneries dans les
lycées mécréant notoire à tes déclarés
il parle de faire condamner pour
escroquerie tout prête qui invoquerait
un miracle l'église étant à ses yeux
l'ennemi de la République aucun
compromis ne lui parait souhaitable
[Musique]
or on murmure à la Chambre
qu'arrive-t-il brillant à dîner avec des
ecclésiastiques pour négocier le texte
et aplanir les difficultés
[Musique]
affine diplomatie du rapporteur n'est
pas du goût de son collègue morissala
qui veut mettre le clergé à genoux en
confisquant purement et simplement les
églises les cathédrales les séminaires
les presbytères et de façon générale
tous les biens mobiliers et immobiliers
des communautés religieuses
dans le texte de la commission les lieux
de culte appartiennent à l'État mais ils
sont mis à la disposition des fidèles
par l'intermédiaire d'associations
culturelles constituée à cet effet
pour Maurice Allard au contraire l'État
doit récupérer les bâtiments pour les
affecter à des usages profanes sont
contre projet pourrait mettre en
difficulté Aristide Briand dont
l'habilité et la modération ne sont pas
appréciées sur tous les bancs de
l'hémicycle
[Applaudissements]
projet de Monsieur Maurice Allard à qui
je donne la parole
je ne me dissimule pas la difficulté de
ma tâche
j'ai contre moi
toute la droite
le centre gauche
la commission
le gouvernement
et probablement une partie de la gauche
qui a déjà approuvé et adopter le texte
du Gouvernement et de la Commission
sans la voir sans doute examinée
suffisamment
à cette partie de la gauche que je
m'adresserai tout particulièrement
tâcher de lui démontrer
que le projet gouvernemental ne
répondent en aucune façon au désiderata
des républicains
je veux débarrasser le débat
de toute considération juridique
oiseaux
ce que je reproche à la Commission
c'est d'avoir méconnu cette différence
essentielle qui existe entre la liberté
de conscience et la liberté religieuse
cette confusion est manifeste dans
l'article premier du texte
gouvernemental qui dit que
la République
assure la liberté de conscience et
garantit le libre exercice des cultes
la liberté religieuse n'est pas la même
chose que la liberté de conscience l'une
peut très bien exister sans l'autre
ce que je reproche à la commission c'est
de voir méconnu cette distinction
car cette distinction en fait nous avons
le droit de ne pas laisser se constituer
au milieu de l'État laïque et contre lui
cet état religieux particulier cette
société religieuse qui devient forcément
un danger véritable quand elle est
animée comme l'église
d'un esprit essentiellement hostile à
tout progrès et à toute civilisation
voilà je crois ce que la Commission n'a
pas compris d'une façon suffisamment
dette il ne faut pas se leurrer sur le
sens du mot séparation
qui n'a aucun sens si on ne lui applique
pas des idées précises
des idées déterminées
il y a tel ou tel séparation dont
l'église peut très bien s'accommoder
mais nous libre penseurs quelle est la
séparation que nous voulons ce ne peut
être que celle qui amènera la diminution
de la malfaisance de l'église et des
religions qu'elle avait
voici le résultat le plus palpable de
votre séparation
au lieu de désarmer l'église vous lui
donnez des armes
tout ce bord n'a lui retirer le budget
des cultes mais vous mettez par contre à
sa disposition des biens soumets jusqu'à
présent au contrôle administratif et
vous les lui abandonner en toute
propriété avec la faculté de les
détourner de leur but et de les employer
à la lutte contre la République
vous spolier la nation au profit de
l'église
c'est c'est bien
qui autrefois était affecté à un service
public
doivent rester affectés à un service
si vous supprimez le service public des
cultes c'est bien trouveront une autre
destination la nation en fera l'usage
qu'elle croira de voir en faire voilà
quelle est la véritable solution la
seule solution et j'ajoute ma solution
équitable une confiscation n'est pas une
solution équitable alors qu'est-ce que
je demande à la gauche
je demande à la gauche de décider que
l'Église
danger politique et danger social doit
être combattue de toutes les façons et
je m'étonne
qu'au moment où nous entreprenons contre
l'Église un combat décisif on nous
demande de déposer les armes et de lui
offrir un projet si libéral tel
qu'elle-même n'aurait jamais osé le
souhaiter
je ne vous dissimule pas
que mon contre-projet
tant à ce que la religion devienne la
chose anormale et que la religion avec
un a privatif devienne la chose normale
je ne vous cache pas que mon
contre-projet tant à décristianisé le
pays
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une opinion j'ai le droit de
l'exposer
je crois monsieur
que le christianisme est un obstacle
permanent au développement social de la
République et la tout progrès vers la
civilisation
il faut le dire très haut il y a
incompatibilité entre l'église et tout
régime républicain
le christianisme est un outrage à la
raison à la nature
il suffit de lire l'histoire pour s'en
convaincre quand le dieu anthropomorphe
des Juifs quitta les bords du Jourdain
pour aller conquérir le monde
méditerranéen la civilisation disparue
du bassin de la Méditerranée et il faut
remercier les empereurs qui ont combattu
de toute leur force l'invasion de cette
philosophie puis héritée
et au naturalisme de notre race
oh le christianisme
qui est à Rome et la Grèce
où il avait été tout fait toutes
civilisations il n'y avait plus que
ruine et des combles quand il arrive à
en France
il n'y ait plu en notre pays ni art ni
lettre ni science
il fallut la Renaissance la Révolution
française pour redonner au cerveau de
notre race sa toute puissance et sa
possibilité de progrès sous l'influence
du judéo christianisme
toute lumière avait disparu il n'y avait
plus que ténèbres
aujourd'hui encore combien de progrès ne
sont pas réalisés parce que nous
traînons derrière nous le lourd boulet
du judéo christianisme avec son cortège
de préjugés et de mensonges
conventionnels
le tourment de l'infini direz-vous ne
faut-il pas le satisfaire
que faisons-nous de l'idéal religieux
il est vrai monsieur
nous avons tous plus ou moins le
tourment de la fini
et je vous assure qu'à gauche nous nous
penchons volontiers sur le problème de
l'infini
mais nous ne cherchons pas à le résoudre
car à nos yeux il ne peut pas être
résolu nous ne comprenons pas l'infini
de la même façon que vous pendant que
vous prétendez détenir la vérité nous
autres nous voulons dire aux hommes et
surtout aux enfants personne ne détient
la vérité
à toi jeune homme
avec l'acquis de ton inspection
avec les données intellectuelles que tu
pourras prendre dans les écoles
publiques et dans tes études
personnelles à toi de te constituer ta
philosophie personnelle et de trouver ta
manière d'envisager le problème de
l'infini
et nous admettons pas qu'un homme le
prêtre viennent nous imposer ces idées
ni dogme ni religion
[Musique]
je veux citer un prospectus que j'ai
reçu
ces auteurs trouvent leurs adresses dans
le Bota et l'envoi à tout le monde il
s'agit des religieuses Franciscaines de
Romorantin
ah ok
les plus hétéroclites pour une somme
modique où vous adressera le scapulaire
de Saint-Antoine propre à faire
retrouver les objets perdus ou encore
une bénédiction miraculeuse de saint
François d'Assise imprimés sur étoffe
avec le portrait
on rentre aussi une amulette dont le
principal effet de favoriser les
accouchements ou la collection des
prières
qui vous font gagner tous les procès
oui oui oui nous protestons comme vous
contre ces pratiques le Christ s'est mis
qu'une fois en colère c'est lorsqu'il a
chassé un coup de fouet les marchands du
temple monsieur Kero
je vous ai sur que comme nous
recherchons un idéal nous n'allons pas
le chercher chez les dames Franciscaines
de Romorantin
alors que voulons-nous nous à gauche et
bien nous voulons que les hommes
se préoccupe un peu plus du monde
extérieur
qu'il sache se faire leur paradis sur
terre sans aller le chercher dans un
monde imaginaire
en attaquant les religions nous faisons
œuvre de progrès social
nous tentons de faire disparaître un des
moyens les plus puissants que possédant
encore la bourgeoisie pour tenir le
peuple en esclavage et c'est pourquoi
messieurs je vous demande de voter mon
contre-projet le seul capable de faire
disparaître ces idées et la diffusion
des idées religieuses des idées
mystiques des idées superstitieuses et
d'émanciper tous ceux qui actuellement
suivent encore les pratiques de certains
cultes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s'il fallait donner un nom aux
contre-projet de Monsieur Allard je
crois qu'on pourrait justement l'appeler
projet de suppression des églises par
l'État très bien
mon lieu de compter sur la seule
puissance de la raison et de la vérité
notre collègue dans sa hâte d'en finir
avec la religion se tourne vers l'état
il l'appelle au secours
il l'appelle au secours de la libre
pensée il le somme
de commettre au service de la Libre
Pensée la même faute qu'il a commise au
service de l'Église et que nous n'avons
cessé nous libre penseurs de lui
reprocher et bien cela ça n'est pas la
conception
de la libre pensée du moins telle que je
n'interprète
nous avons déposé devant la chambre un
projet de séparation très net mais en
même temps très large très équitable
sachant concilier les droits et les
intérêts de l'État avec le souci de la
liberté de conscience
c'est à l'heure actuelle le seul projet
dont le vote soit possible et
j'ajouterai même désirable
je supplie mes amis d'extrême gauche
de résister au désirs de faire une
manifestation anticléricale qui non
seulement resterait inefficace
et pour émettre aux mains des ennemis de
la République une arme dangereuse je
connais mon ami à la
je sais combien il est perspicace à Visé
je connais son attachement à la
République et je reste convaincu qu'en
déposant son contre-projet il aura
surtout voulu exposer devant la Chambre
sa doctrine philosophique en matière de
religion et ben moi je me félicite de
cette initiative car elle nous aura
permis d'entendre un discours plein de
verbes de fantaisie et d'originalité
enfin surtout beaucoup de fantaisies et
d'ailleurs alors aussi permis à ce côté
de l'assemblée de constater qu'il y a
des nuances et qu'entre le contre-projet
de Monsieur Maurice Allard et celui de
la commission certaines distances
restent à parcourir
monsieur brillant
monsieur brillant n'a répondu que de
façon très sommaire à mes arguments j'ai
dit qu'il y avait un grand danger pour
la République à offrir en toute
propriété aux associations culturelles
qui seront en même temps des
associations politiques des biens qui
sont en réalité des biens nationaux le
danger est ainsi de maintenir l'unité de
l'Église et d'empêcher l'église après la
séparation de se diviser en petites
églises et en petites associations
cultuelles vous maintenez ainsi l'unité
du bloc romain nous n'avons pas à
provoquer des schisme mais enfin nous ne
sommes pas là non plus pour les empêcher
la parole est à Monsieur Jean Jaurès
[Musique]
Jean Jaurès prépare son discours à 45
ans le député du Tarn s'est imposé comme
le chef de fil des socialistes français
normaniens professeur de philosophie
c'est lui qui en avril 1905 s'apprête à
fédérer les différentes tendances du
mouvement ouvrier en un seul et même
parti politique la SFIO section
française de l'international ouvrière
de l'unité l'homme de la synthèse
lecteur de Karl Marx il ne fait pourtant
pas de la lutte des classes le moteur de
l'histoire le socialisme selon Jaurès
n'est que l'approfondissement de l'idéal
républicain l'application à la propriété
de la Déclaration des droits de l'homme
et du citoyen
sur la séparation le grand tribun a
d'abord étonné en gardant le silence
partisan de la laïcité Jaurès n'est pas
pour autant fermé aux idées religieuses
ses propres amis en 1901 avaient
d'ailleurs été scandalisé d'apprendre
que sa fille Madeleine avait fait sa
première communion
[Musique]
on sait maintenant que le silence de
chorest était purement tactique le
leader socialiste peaufine ses arguments
son papier restera dans sa poche car je
reste parle sans aucun texte sous les
yeux mais les députés s'attendent un
discours décisif
[Musique]
si les associations cultuelles se
constituaient en dehors de la hiérarchie
ecclésiastique sur un modèle
démocratique de multiples dissidences
viendraient rompre l'unité de l'Église
catholique et ruinée l'autorité du pape
c'est ce que recherche les anticléricaux
à rester brillant qui ménage l'église
pour assurer les modérer doit aussi
convaincre les libres penseurs pour
avoir une majorité
[Musique]
la gauche va-t-elle s'unir ou se diviser
la parole est
tous les observateurs s'accordent à
reconnaître qu'un éclatement du corps
républicain serait fatale à la
séparation
[Musique]
monsieur c'est toi va attribuer demain
des biens
à des associations cultuelles
régulièrement investir en harmonie
avec l'organisation de l'Église
catholique
on a dit qu'on ne voulait pas préparer
de gismes
mais qu'on ne voulait pas non plus les
empêcher
et pendant il en est
qui paraissent concevoir que l'Église
catholique sera
diminué dans sa puissance
non par Le Progrès direct
de la pensée libre et de la science
mais par je ne sais quelle
quelle
déliquescence obscure du dogme
où ils espèreraient entrevoir un jour
je ne sais quelle
nuance de schisme vaguement assorti à
leurs aspirations intérieures
je ne voudrais pas me donner un air
d'autres cuit dense en résumant en une
formule trop simple le génie de
l'histoire même de notre pays mais je
crois pouvoir dire historiquement ceci
la France n'est pas
schisme elle est
révolutionnaire
[Applaudissements]
comme autant lointain ou les barbares
francs se faisaient contre les autres
barbares
les serviteurs et les exécuteurs de la
pensée de l'évêque de Rome
puis quand notre pays
échappe aux prises de Rome quand il se
dresse contre elle
il ne se refuse point à 2000 ne se
résugit pas dans l'incertitude des
compromis
lorsque
au 12e et 13e siècle
notre
intrépide ardents
France méridionale
se lever contre le despotisme d'église
ce n'est pas un schisme
ce n'est même pas une hérésie qu'elle
promener c'était toute une autre
métaphysique toute une autre religion
puis au 16e siècle
quand ce grand mouvement de la réforme
se produit quand éclate c'est admirable
réveil des consciences individuelles
ce mouvement grandit en Allemagne il
grandit en Angleterre et en Hollande en
France il se heurte à la résistance de
l'immense majorité pourquoi
est-ce parce que la France était
au-dessous de la réforme non messieurs
c'est parce que déjà de grands génies
comme
Rabelais avait entrevu toute la grandeur
future de la science libre
parce qu'ils avaient glorifié
symboliquement les voiles de la vie mais
tentant de communication les terres et
les mers et aussi les livres
les papiers de ces livres qui mettent en
communication les esprits
[Musique]
plus haut encore
après avoir conquis les mères et la
terre
elle s'élèvera vers les hauteurs de
l'espace
et devant sans Hugo il annonçait
l'humanité ira loger un jour annoncé des
étoiles
c'est par ce que notre génie français
avait cette admirable audace d'espérance
et d'affirmation dans la pensée libre
qu'il sait réservé dans la réforme afin
de se conserver tout entier pour la
révolution
toute notre histoire proteste
contre je ne sais quelle tentation de
substituer les compromis incertains et
attenant du schisme à la marche
délibérée de l'esprit vers la pleine
lumière vers la pleine science et
entière raison
c'est
sans équivoque c'est sans ambiguïté
c'est en respectant
dans la limite même de leur
fonctionnement les principes
d'organisation des églises
et c'est en dressant contre ses églises
la grande association des hommes
travaillant au culte nouveau de la
justice sociale et de l'humanité
renouvelée
c'est par là
et non par des schisme incertains que
vous ferez progresser ce pays
conformément à son génie
voilà pourquoi
le vrai
que la Commission nous soumet œuvre de
loyauté
œuvre
Hardy dans son fond mais qui ne cache
aucun piège qui ne dissimule aucune
l'arrière-pensée
est conforme ou véritable génie de la
France républicaine
nous ne faisons pas
une œuvre de brutalité
nous ne faisons pas une œuvre
de sournoiserie
nous faisons une œuvre
de sincérité
c'est
le caractère du travail de la commission
et voilà pourquoi je m'y rallie
c'est pas ce que notre génie français
avait cette admirable audace d'espérance
et d'affirmation dans la pensée libre
qu'il sait réservé dans la réforme afin
de se conserver tout entier pour la
révolution
nous faisons une oeuvre
de sincérité
je mets au point le contre-projet de
Monsieur Maurice Allard qui est pour
qui contre
[Musique]
il n'est pas adopté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la chambre est en revenue au texte de la
commission les députés sont lisent
pendant plusieurs semaines dans l'examen
des amendements le gouvernement restait
étonnamment absent de la discussion trop
heureux de faire durer un débat qui
retarde forte fortunément l'ouverture de
dossiers sensibles comme l'instauration
d'un impôt sur le revenu ou la création
de retraite ouvrière
[Musique]
Maurice Allard n'a pas renoncé à faire
de la provocation les anticléricaux
réclament le remplacement des fêtes
religieuses par des jours fériés laïques
certains prônent l'interdiction de la
soutane
mais les libres penseurs ne voient pas
qu'en faisant de l'assurancechère
il rend service à Aristide Briand
[Musique]
à droite et jusqu'au sein de l'Église
les plus raisonnables commencent à voir
le texte de la Commission comme un
moindre mal
seule une fraction du monde catholique
refuse en bloc le débat Armand de Baudry
Dassault demeure intransigeant député
royaliste de la Vendée Commandeur de
l'Ordre pontifical de Saint-Grégoire le
Grand il défend l'alliance du trône et
de l'hôtel pour lui point de salut sans
la monarchie
un de ses ancêtres est tombé les armes à
la main en luttant contre les
républicains
il en est fier
député des sables de l'homme depuis 29
ans le compte de Baudry Dasson n'a
jamais cessé de combattre la République
en 1880 déjà il s'est montré 6 virulent
que Gambetta qui présidait la chambre
l'avait fait saisir dans l'hémicycle
après une bagarre mémorable avec les
gardes républicains le compte fut
enfermé pendant 24 heures il passe à la
nuit petit local la cellule de
dégrisement du Palais Bourbon
grand propriétaire éleveur de chevaux
Armand de baudridation n'obéit à
personne
sportif combattif il a mené la vie dure
au Cabinet des Mille Combes
[Musique]
le vieil aristocrate peut encore cogner
mais son combat est-il toujours le même
que celui de l'église la baie des roues
en effet semble s'éloigner de son allié
vendéen la parole est à Monsieur l'abbé
Guerault
messieurs vous ne savez accordé des
satisfactions considérables en rédigeant
le texte de façon apparaît au péril de
schisme et en nous garantissant la
jouissance gratuite et indéfinie des
édifices du culte mais ma conscience
m'oblige à vous demander messieurs que
la loi de séparation soit respectueuse
des exigences de ma foi il faut que vous
le sachiez la constitution de l'Église
catholique n'est pas une constitution
démocratique nous savions depuis
longtemps monsieur Gayraud ce qui ne
veut pas dire que l'Église catholique
n'aime pas la démocratie
la constitution de l'église est une
constitution monarchique
vous devez rien à traduire dans la loi
qui soit contraire à cette organisation
votre texte ne pourra être acceptable
pour nous qu'autant qu'il a été accepté
par le Saint Siège d'être plus pas plus
que le pape si vous voulez ouvrir une
aire d'agitation religieuse faites-le
quant à moi je ne m'y associerai pas je
protège dès maintenant contre votre
tyrannie j'envoie parole qui tente à
ouvrir cet air protestant contre ce
langage je te broderie d'assaut pour
être digne de la liberté faut d'abord
savoir respecter la liberté d'autrui en
fait de liberté monsieur brillant vous
n'êtes pas brillants
monsieur de Baudry Dasson vous m'oblige
à constater que jusqu'ici cette
discussion c'est poursuivie dans le
calme
j'estime qu'un catholique digne de ce
nom qu'un royaliste dévoué
ne peut voter ce texte
je voudrais donc contre au nom de la
France catholique
et de la liberté
j'étais à la peine j'étais au combat
je veux rester jusqu'au jour où sonnera
l'heure de la prospérité pour notre
malheureux pays l'heure du relèvement
national
l'heure du bonheur et de la joie l'heure
de la délivrance et pour cela il faut
d'abord arrêter les persécutions
religieuses
vieux avec nous
qui empêche nos enfants de connaître
Dieu plus de ses lois abominables qui
permettent de chasser nos religieux plus
de spoliation honteux plus de ses vols
véritables je déposerai un projet sur le
bureau de la Chambre ayant pour but
d'expulser ou même de coller au mur tous
les traîtres à la patrie
[Musique]
je vous rappelle à l'ordre
je vous prie de respecter le déroulement
de la séance
[Musique]
vive la France catholique vive la France
aux français
[Applaudissements]
nous allons maintenant examiner
l'amendement de Monsieur Maurice Allard
visant à décider que cesseront d'être
jour fériés tous ceux qui n'auront pas
pour objet exclusifs la célébration
d'événements civils
la parole est à Monsieur Maurice Allard
je connais
quand demain nous aurons voté la
séparation
la République
par un illogisme choquant
fêtera encore la naissance du Christ sa
résurrection son ascension au ciel je
crois que si nous voulons vraiment que
la laïcisation ne soit pas un vin mot
nous devons supprimer les jours fériés
religieux
je ne vous demande que de leur
substituer des jours fériés laïques de
même que l'Église emprunta autrefois au
paganisme ces jours fériés je demande
que nous empruntions aujourd'hui à
l'église ces jours de fête
à Noël nous fêterons le solstice d'hiver
à la Saint Jean le solstice d'été à
Pâques au lieu de célébrer la
résurrection miraculeuse d'un mystique
nommé Jésus dont l'existence même est
hypothétique et bien nous célébrons la
renaissance de
l'afghanie je demande à la chambre
pour une laïcisation complète de l'état
de voter mon amende
il y a malgré toute sa poésie cet
amendement a été repoussé par la
commission
mais ma vie du gouvernement
je le mets au vois qui est pour
contre
et n'est pas adopté
je suis saisi d'un nouvel amendement de
Monsieur Maurice Allard visant à
interdire le port du costume
ecclésiastique en ville
de mieux en mieux
mes chers collègues
nous ne pouvons voir dans le prêtre un
citoyen comme tout autre puisque c'est
lui qui part ses prétentions ces
affirmations se mettent en dehors du
droit commun question sera différente
sans doute le jour où le prêtre
consentira de plus parler comme un être
qui s'élève au-dessus de la société tout
entière elle est plus être le
représentant direct de Dieu cela
messieurs vous me l'accorderez
volontiers le met vraiment dans une
situation privilégiée dans notre société
parler à Dieu par les au nom de Dieu
c'est une chose considérable énorme le
prêtre n'est pas un être comme vous et
moi le prêtre ouvrait formation gré les
portes du paradis et celle de l'enfer
c'est terrible cela Monsieur Gairaut
le prêtre dispose sur les masses
crédules d'une influence que nous
n'avons pas nous autres propagandistes
qui parcourant les villes en jaquette et
en palto parlez-nous donc des tabliers
des francs-maçons
nous sommes des hommes comme les autres
et le prêtre qui a devant lui un hommage
nouillé qui passe pour avoir entre ses
mains des destinées futures ah mais
monsieur se prêtre est puissant il le
maître de cette pauvre conscience qu'il
menace des peines terribles et il a pars
suite une puissance d'action que ne
possède pas le plus éloquent nos
orateurs vous avez les préfets pour vous
messieurs
au risque d'étonner notre norable au
collègue je lui dirai que le silence du
projet de loi au sujet du costume
éclésiastique qui semble le préoccuper
si fort
n'est pas le résultat d'une émission
mais bien au contraire
d'une délibération mûrement réfléchie en
effet il est apparu à la commission que
ce serait encourir pour un résultat plus
que problématique le reproche
d'intolérance et même de s'exposer un
danger plus grave encore le ridicule
très bien
parce que notre collègue cherche à
atteindre dans la soutane c'est le moyen
qu'elle procure de se distinguer plus
facilement des autres citoyens mais la
sout
ane il faut supprimer l'ingéniosité
combinée des tailleurs et des prêtres
auraient offé de créer un vêtement
nouveau qui serait plus la soutane
mais qui se distinguera encore assez du
veston pour permettre au passant
distinguer au premier coup d'oeil après
quant au prestige de l'Église dans nos
campagnes seraient téméraires de la
tribuer uniquement à la forme du
vêtement des prêtres l'influence de
l'Église tient à d'autres causes
beaucoup plus difficile à détruire sinon
il y a bien longtemps que la Libre
Pensée aurait triomphé du dogme Monsieur
Alain
c'est amendement a-t-il le plus de
succès que le précédent
il n'est pas adopté
[Applaudissements]
à Monsieur Aristide Briand rapporteur de
la commission
le 3 juillet 1905 après 3 mois et demi
de débat les députés doivent se
prononcer sur l'ensemble du texte
Aristide Briand malgré la fatigue
s'apprête à livrer une dernière bataille
le petit député de la Loire va-t-il
gagner son Paris l'effacement du
ministre des Cultes donne la vedette au
rapporteur de la commission
encore inconnue au début de l'année
Aristide Briand est maintenant une
célébrité nationale
cette loi qui l'a défendu seul est
devenue sa loi il souhaite qu'elle soit
votée à la plus large majorité dans
l'hémicycle mais il veut aussi qu'elle
soit comprise et acceptée dans le pays
la France de 1905 ne peut prendre le
risque de se déchirer sur la question
religieuse
le Kaiser Guillaume II a Clermont fait
connaître son ambition de contrôler le
Maroc c'est la crise de Tanger entre
Paris et Berlin le thon monte la guerre
franco-allemande menace éclatée
pour Aristide Briand le succès personnel
est acquis je donne à la parole sur
l'ensemble du texte à Monsieur Aristide
Briand rapporteur de la commission
mais en montant à la tribune il sait que
la paix civile la Concorde l'Union des
Français doit être à tout prix préserver
c'est un homme d'État qui est en train
de naître
les hommes ne sont parfois que trop
portés à nier tout progrès qui ne
s'affirme pas par une violence au
détriment dans adversaire
je tiens à le dire hautement le progrès
ainsi compris n'est pas dans ma manière
dans ce pays où des millions de
catholiques pratiquent leur religion les
uns par conviction réelles d'autres par
habitude par tradition de famille
il était impossible d'envisager une
séparation qui ne puisse accepter on m'a
fait grève de certaines concessions au
centre et à la droite
messieurs si j'avais fait de cette
réforme une question d'amour propre
personnel comme on peut y être porté
quand on s'exalte devant la grandeur de
sa tâche et qu'on se laisse entraîner au
désir de la marquer exclusivement de son
empreinte si je n'avais eu que cette
misérable préoccupation personnelle
c'était l'irrémédiable échec
j'ai compris autrement mon devoir j'ai
voulu réussir dans l'accomplissement de
la tâche qui m'avait été confiée pour
cela sans perdre de vue un seul instant
les principes essentiels de la réforme
qui tousse
ont été respectées je n'ai pas reculé
devant les concessions nécessaires si
ceux de nos collègues qui ont combattu
le principe de la séparation veulent
bien porter sur notre œuvre un jugement
selon leur conscience ils seront bien
forcés de reconnaître que nous avons
fait pour le mieux
maintenant messieurs permettez-moi de
vous dire que la réalisation de cette
réforme aura pour effet désirable
d'affranchir ce pays d'une véritable
hantise sous l'influence de laquelle il
n'a que trop négligée tant d'autres
questions importantes d'ordre
économiques
ou social ces grands problèmes se
poseront demain
des corons disparus des programmes
politiques les questions irritantes qui
comme celles-ci passionnent les esprits
jusqu'à la haine et gaspille en discorde
stérile les forces les plus vives de la
nation la réforme que nous allons voter
laissera le champ libre à l'activité
républicaine et pour qu'il en fut ainsi
il fallait que la séparation ne donne
pas de signal de lutte confessionnelle
il fallait que la loi se montra
respectueuse de toutes les croyances et
leur laissa la faculté de s'exprimer
librement
nous l'avons faite de telles sortent que
l'Église ne puisse invoquer aucun
prétexte pour s'insurger contre le
nouvel état de choses pas du tout c'est
scandaleux c'est une hôte
je ne comprends pas les interruptions de
vos amis pas plus que je ne m'explique
davantage des paroles que vous
prononciez au début de cette discussion
quand vous disiez vous prétendez
accorder la liberté à l'église et vous
lui enlever le budget d'études mais
monsieur Gayraud
qu'il église ne peut se passer des
subsides de l'état c'est que l'Église
est déjà morte je n'ai jamais dit cela
Monsieur brillant et bien si ça dépend
votre opinion alors vous devez vous
tenir pour satisfaire de la loi que nous
avons fait en tout cas vous ne pourrez
plus demain
catholique de France que la majorité
républicaine de cette chambre c'est
montré à votre égard persécutrice et
tyrannique car elle vous aura
généreusement accordé tout ce que
raisonnablement vos consciences
pouvaient exiger la justice et la
liberté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la loi de Séparation des Églises et de
l'État est adoptée à la Chambre des
députés par 341 fois contre 233
son discours final est affiché dans les
36 000 communes de France
[Musique]
votez conforme par le Sénat le 6
décembre 1905 la loi est promulguée le 9
décembre et paraît au Journal Officiel
le 11
au début de l'année 1906 son application
de lieu à des violences graves les
agents de l'État qui viennent
inventorier les biens contenus dans les
églises ce hurt au prêtre et aux
croyants qui refusent l'ouverture des
tabernacles
la crise des inventaires fait tomber le
gouvernement dans le nouveau cabinet
Aristide Briand est nommé ministre des
cultes
avec Clémenceau ministre de l'Intérieur
la décision est prise de suspendre les
inventaires et d'appliquer la loi en
douceur
c'est pour brillant le début d'une
carrière ministérielle sans équivalent
évoluant vers le centre l'ancien
rapporteur de la loi de séparation sera
25 fois ministre et 11 fois président du
Conseil un record inégalé
le père Gayraud malade meurt en cours de
mandat le 16 décembre 1911
Armand de Baudry Dassault aux élections
de 1914 laisse sa circonscription à son
fils après 38 ans de mandat il s'éteint
l'année suivante sur cette aire de
Vendée
Jean Jaurès le tribun de la paix est
assassiné le 31 juillet 1914 à la veille
de la Première Guerre mondiale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans les tranchées les ricos et
anticléricaux partagent les mêmes
épreuves
à la fin de la guerre
l'Alsace et la Moselle redevienne
française mais elles obtiennent un
statut religieux particulier
dans les années 1920
Aristide Briand deviendra l'artisan du
rapprochement franco-allemand ce qui lui
vaudra le prix Nobel de la paix en 1926
c'est à la tribune de la Société des
Nations en 1931 il s'adresse au
gouvernement du monde entier
[Applaudissements]
nous n'acceptons pas que dans aucun cas
pour aucune cause dans aucune
circonstance la guerre que nous avons
cloué au pyloris comme un crime puissant
réveiller contre les autres
mais Aristide Briand échoue à conquérir
les Lisée et se retire dans sa propriété
de Cocherel en Normandie
les parlementaires lui préfèrent Paul
Doumer l'ancien président de la Chambre
devenu président du Sénat
élu à la présidence de la République le
13 mai 1931 Paul Doumer est assassiné
moins d'un an plus tard par un fou qui
se réclame du fascisme
[Musique]
la République est en deuil les années
noires ont commencé
[Musique]
après la mort d'Aristide Briand le 7
mars 1932
Maurice Allard reste le dernier grand
témoin du débat de 1905
battu en 1910 est redevenu simple
journaliste il vivra jusqu'au 27
novembre 1942
il verra sous l'Occupation le
gouvernement de Vichy rechercher l'appui
de l'église
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais de nombreux croyants rejoignent la
résistance
les forment à la Libération à un
important mouvement de démocratie
chrétienne
la laïcité prend une valeur
constitutionnelle dans le préambule de
la Constitution française de 1946
une valeur confirmée en 1958 dans la
Constitution de la Cinquième République
la France est une République indivisible
laïque démocratique et sociale elle
assure l'égalité devant la loi de tous
les citoyens sans distinction d'origine
de race ou de religion elle respecte
toutes les croyances
les relations entre la République et
l'église s'apaisent la présence du
général de Gaulle au Vatican a permis
aux souverain intentif de rappeler que
l’œuvre entreprise actuellement par la
France devait favoriser les intérêts de
tous les peuples ce que ce sont dit le
chef de la chrétienté et le chef de la
nation française et demeurer secret mais
ici comme à Milan et comme au curinal ce
sont des liens chaleureux qui ont été
renoués
[Musique]
en 1989 la rentrée scolaire est
perturbée par un incident inattendu
trois jeunes musulmanes qui refusent
doter leur foulard en cours sont exclus
du collège Gabriel Havez de Creil
[Musique]
motif atteinte à la laïcité et à la
neutralité de l'école publique
[Musique]
le problème n'est pas des croyances le
problème est de la manifestation
extérieure de cette croyance dans
l'enceinte des locaux scolaires et
notamment en classe de nouveau la France
s'interroge sur la laïcité
[Musique]
nous avons fait le choix libre
maintenant que nous l'avons fait rien ne
pourra nous en détourner la loi de 1905
revient au centre du débat public
s d'enfants qui vont à l'école notamment
mais qui ne sont pas les seuls il y a
aussi d'autres signes religieux
actuellement présent à l'école mais
notamment avec un foulard sur la tête je
préconise de les directeurs
d'établissement et les enseignants
disent à ses enfants et à leurs parents
qui ne doivent pas venir à l'école dans
ces conditions si il y a blocage et s'il
y a refus jeudi alors l'école doit
accepter et accueillir des enfants le
gouvernement Rocard s'en était remis au
Conseil d'État
celui-ci dans son avis du 27 novembre
1989 n'avait plus que rappeler le droit
en vigueur
[Musique]
si le port de signe religieux n'est pas
en soi incompatible avec le principe de
laïcité et constitue même une liberté il
ne doit pas prendre un caractère
ostentatoire ou revendicatif ni devenir
un acte de pression de provocation de
prosélytisme ou de propagande et ne doit
en aucun cas porter atteinte à la
dignité de l'élève ainsi le port de
signe religieux peut être réglementé
dans le même esprit la circulaire
Beyrout de 1994 distingue les signes
discrets des signes ostentatoires le 11
décembre 2003 la Commission Stasi sur la
laïcité rend son rapport au président de
la République le 17 décembre Jacques
Chirac se déclare favorable à
l'enseignement du fer religieux et
souhaite une loi contre le port
ostensible de signes religieux à l'école
j'estime que le port de tenue ou de
signes qui manifeste
ostensiblement l'appartenance religieux
doit être proscrit dans les écoles les
collèges et les lycées publics
[Musique]
une mission parlementaire d'information
est constituée sous la présidence de
Jean-Louis Debré cette démarche aboutit
à la loi du 15 mars 2004 selon laquelle
dans les écoles les collèges et les
lycées publics le port de signe ou tenu
par lesquels les élèves manifestent
ostensiblesment une appartenance
religieuse est interdite
[Musique]
le modèle français de laïcité ne
signifie pas la négation du fait
religieux
l'homme ne serait pas l'homme s'il ne
s'interrogeait pas sur l'origine du
monde et la fin des choses
le don de la vie et l'énigme de la mort
le lien mystérieux de la matière et de
l'esprit la conscience que chacun a de
lui-même comment en rendre compte
les hommes se posent tous les mêmes
questions mais il diffère sur les voies
de la connaissance
faut-il préférer la raison logique
la méditation intérieure la révélation
d'en haut
cette recherche n'est pas seulement
individuelle
les prophètes les messies les apôtres
ont laissé aux différents peuples de la
terre des règles de vie
des articles de foi la morale issue des
livres sacrés quelques fois sévère
le culte peut prendre des formes
visibles démonstratives exaltées même
[Musique]
chacun dans sa courte existence ses
forces de trouver son chemin
[Musique]
celui qui croit au ciel voudrait tourner
toutes les âmes vers son Dieu
celui qui n'y croit pas aimerait libérer
les hommes de leur croyances s'il le
faut malgré eux l'un dans sa ferveur
souhaite renforcer la religion par la
puissance de l'État pour soumettre les
hommes à la loi divine l'autre dans sa
sagesse demande qu'on distingue le
pouvoir politique du pouvoir religieux
le compromis de 1905 nous vient en
héritage
la laïcité n'est pas une croyance de
plus ni une religion de l'incroyance
elle signifie la neutralité de l'État en
matière de religion
c'est elle qui permet à toutes les
croyances de coexister en paix dans un
même pays elle garantit à chacun la
liberté de croire et celle de ne pas
croire
la liberté de pratiquer et celle de ne
pas pratiquer
elle donne à tous la faculté la plus
rare dans le monde
et la plus précieuse pour l'esprit
la liberté de douter
[Musique]
aujourd'hui comme hier
la laïcité et notre bien commun
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]